[MUSIC]
Good morning, good afternoon,
good evening.
Wherever you are tuning in from we're so
excited to see you all here at,
Your Journey Now ''I know"
from Diverse Leaders events.
Where we're going to hear from a group of,
really awesome Panelists,
a group of alumni of the GSB.
My name is Jessica Chang.
I'm an admissions officer at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And I'm just really,
really grateful that you are spending
a little bit of your day with us today.
So, I want to start by going over
what today's event will look like.
We'll start with a brief
introduction to our community.
We're going to introduce our panelists.
I have a few prepared questions for
them, just to get us warmed up.
And in the meantime, please submit
your own questions in the Q&A box.
You can feel free to get a little
practice in the q&a box and
let us know your name and
where you're tuning in from.
We always love seeing who's
in the zoom room with us.
And then we'll turn to your
questions in the Q&A box.
You can also use the up voting feature.
If you see somebody has submitted
a question that really resonates with you,
and that way we can try to address some of
the most pressing questions for the group.
Overall, we're going to spend
about 55 minutes together.
With a goal of introducing you all to
our GSB community to leaders who have
come from our community and represent all
different experiences and backgrounds.
We're going to take a look in the Q&A
box just because I am curious
about who's in the Zoom Room
with us today.
Hello, Frank from Providence Rhode Island,
Paula from Columbia,
Nicole from Miami, Mike from California.
Hello, Gwen from Atlanta,
Pooja from San Francisco,
Nate from Florida, Gray from Spain,
Stacy from Canada, Nana from Malaysia.
Wow, it's so good to see you all.
And it's awesome because in some ways
this is like a microcosm of what
it's like to be at the GSB,
where our community really comes from all
over the country and all over the world.
So this is very very exciting for
us to see where you all
are tuning in from today.
So a little bit about our community and
then I think you'll get a much deeper
sense of what our community is like
over the course of today's panel.
Our community includes over 30,000
alumni who are all over the country and
all over the world.
We have 60 volunteer led regional
chapters of alumni around the world so
it's truly a community for life.
And on our campus we have a variety
of student organizations,
women's programs, diversity programs.
There are many, many different ways
to engage on our community both
as a student and as an alumni.
Next, I would like to turn
it over to our panelists to
introduce themselves going
in alphabetical order.
Adriana, you want to kick us off?
>> Sure.
Hi everyone.
Really happy to be here,
another anapana I am class of 2012.
My background is in undergrad,
I went to NYU,
I have a double major in psychology and
sociology.
I worked at PepsiCo in
Mexico before the GSB.
After the GSB, now I'm in Tech,
and I'm working for Facebook.
But I've had a journey of I did
management, consulting, FinTech, and
now I'm in advertising.
So I'm really happy to be here.
>> Awesome, thank you.
Alejandro, do you want to
introduce yourself?
>> Everyone,
I'm Alejandro Gerecht class of 2019.
So my background,
I studied mechanical engineering at MIT,
spent a few years after
undergrad in Boston worked
at Liberty Mutual Insurance
doing data analytics work.
When I was looking for roles at GSB,
I was focused on startup recruiting.
So I ended up actually using the GSB
alumni network to land an internship and
my first role out of GSB.
And now I'm currently working at
an early stage startup called worthwhile
that is building a labor marketplace
to help hourly workers find jobs.
>> Awesome.
Thank you, Jessica.
>> And I'm Jessica, Alejandro's classmate.
I went to Howard for
undergrad and before the GSB.
I worked in private equity and then.
In the food space and then after
the GSB actually went into venture and
now I'm back in private equity.
So I've also covered a quite
a realm of different industries and
ended up starting my own private equity
firm which is the century partners.
>> Awesome, thank you all so much.
One of our panelists has not yet
joined us, which is totally fine.
Hopefully she'll be able to
join us later in the session.
Before we dive into the session,
I do want to note that this is hopefully
just one stop along your journey.
You can continue your journey if you
haven't already at MyStanford.mba.
Where you can create a personalized
dashboard to keep track of your
application browse different parts of
student life and academic life at the GSB.
And learn more about our events and
stay in touch with us.
So with that I'm going to
stop screen share.
And I do have a few prepared questions for
our panelists.
As I said, for our attendees,
please feel free to submit
your questions in the Q&A box.
We love to hear what you
want to learn about today.
So my first question for our panelists is.
Why did you decide to pursue an MBA and
why did you decide to pursue
an MBA at Stanford specifically?
>> I can go first.
I think the reasons why I wanted to pursue
is different than what happened later.
So, I was in Mexico,
I studied the US came back to Mexico, and
I was a psychology major working on
business process re-engineering.
And so what I thought I needed or
why I thought I needed an MBA, so
I had fundamental gaps around business,
and I think going into it.
What I learned was it was a lot more
about a journey of personal professional
transformation would be very focused
on personal transformation and
how I can be a better leader.
But other tools that you can
actually use as you grow and
mature into organizations and
what was the second question,
so, a
>> Why Stanford MBA.
Why Stanford because of that part,
I was really keen.
I had a really strong
psychology background and
I was really keen on human development.
And now I think with design thinking and
touchy feely like it's become a lot
more popular across other schools, but
at that time, it was six Explicitly at
Stanford and I think it's the best place.
Honestly to learn about that and
that Stanford is a place where
vulnerability is expected.
And that's really uncomfortable and I am
just really glad I went to the GSB and
any was a hugely
transformational process for me.
>> Absolutely, and for I think a lot
of our audience members might be
familiar with interpersonal dynamics,
which our alums often call touchy feely.
But can you say a little bit
about what that classes?
>> Yeah, so it's a class where you
understand how your actions and
your words going to impact.
The other person and how to make sure
you create deep connections actually,
there's a new book that's
highly recommended.
It's connecting If they're going to
know the name better than me, but
I read in on Carl when they had the book.
I can just go, personally, I'm part
of the LGBT community, I was not out.
It was a time where in Mexico is very
complicated, and through the GSBI gained
security and the safety among my
classmates to actually come out.
And that I think that's a process of
transformation that was really critical
on accepting myself as a true and
authentic leader.
And that I have carried through my career.
>> Awesome, thanks for
sharing that with us.
>> So why MBA piece for me was connected
to realizing that the growth of my
career was not based on just hard work,
but also networks.
So it was when I looked at the opportunity
to do an MBA, could not do an MBA and
work really hard at
finding other connections.
And connections outside of my industry and
where I was in New York.
Or I could use an MBA
is like a catalyst for
growth to meet people that I
never would have liked, met.
Or have been very difficult to try
to arrange an international cohort,
cross industry, cross country of people.
And so I recognize that as having a lot
of value after a couple of years outside
of work.
And I would say, I mean,
hopefully it's not surprising,
by Stanford MBA delivered on that and
maybe a hundred fold.
I think I was a little bit,
maybe pessimistic isn't the word, but
realistic about what
the MBA could give me.
Everyone's this going to be
a life changing experience and
you're going to come out of
it some supercharged person.
So I was just a little bit realistic about
what it could mean for me, but in reality,
I would say that my, and
you don't really call it a network.
It's your friends, people that care about
you and not just outside of my class,
but my class professors, other people
who are just randomly contented.
As the results of the experience
is truly just like so meaningful.
So where I am today and
why I chose Stanford was really,
it's kind of really cheesy, but
it's really in the DNA of what it means.
And it's just clearly stated in
the byline of change lives change
organizations change the world.
And just like an intent
across my classmates and
intent across a broader GASB community,
I think substantively about the world that
we want to create and that we want to see.
And not to say that everyone agrees
on what that looks like, but
we all agree that there has to be change.
We have to put in the work to make
better world for like not only us, but
future generations.
So I felt like that really underpinned
what people thought about or
how they move through the world and
I really appreciated that.
And so I chose Stanford, even though I
applied to seven or eight schools [LAUGH].
>> Yeah, so why MBA for me is something
a couple years after undergrad I was
going to hit a fork in the road of what
it was that I thought I wanted to pursue.
I was in a data analyst position.
So basically I was either going to go
do a data science program a PhD and
stats or do an MBA.
My boss and my mentor at the time
was a business school grad.
And so that's when I started to kind of
understand what could come from that type
of skill set or we can develop there.
I think personally I had always been
more focused heads down on what
the technical work and
not really considering on the network.
The power of relationships
within business context.
So that's something that was appealing for
me.
And honestly,
even more than that was the optionality,
like having two years to explore and learn
a lot about like what actually excites me,
which honestly was the biggest value,
the GSB or just an MBA in general.
And the why Stanford specifically,
I think there's probably three
specific things that come to mind.
So one is wanting to dive
into startup ecosystem.
I come from working at two very,
very large companies.
Prior to the GSB, so
startup kind of ecosystem
community was very foreign to me.
I didn't really know anything about it.
So I wanted to basically
dive headfirst into that.
The second was kind of the whole
touchy feely culture of the GSB,
not just the class, but just the idea
that the what that class represents is
kind of embedded into lots
of other aspects of the GSB.
And I got that from speaking to alumni,
students and
admissions officers at the time
when I was searching for,
they made it very clear that this was
an opportunity to develop personally.
Not just professionally,
which honestly ended up being the reason
why I decided to go to Stanford.
And the final choice,
I'm from Los Angeles, and
I was tired of being on the East Coast.
I wanted to come back to California.
[LAUGH]
>> Awesome, thank you all for
sharing those reflections.
I feel like each of you touched
on Sort of the distinctive
GSB community in different ways.
And the this shared culture of
vulnerability, authenticity, and
we sort of call it principled leadership,
people centric leadership.
Are there any, when you think
back on your time at the GSB,
are there any favorite memories or
favorite moments that you feel
really capture the essence of the GSB
community and GSB family for you?
>> Well, the highlight, which is what
most people get to experience once you
get accepted or come for
the weekend is talk.
And they might do this at other
opportunities or other junctures.
But I think that there's
not one particular talk,
but it's over every week where
people are sharing their story.
And being very vulnerable and
open about whatever it is,
it doesn't have to be some kind of crazy,
overcome some huge mountain type of story.
But it's really that ethos of who
they are and what matters to them.
I always think of it as an extension of
what matters most to you and why question.
That is traditionally what
have has been more or less.
I don't know if it's an essay anymore,
but anyway.
>> It is.
[LAUGH]
>> Application essay questions.
And so
it's great to get a window into people.
And I think what comes out of that is
the vulnerability piece that we mentioned.
It's the connection to people and
realizing that everyone as
is their own little iceberg,
there's just so much underneath that
you don't traditionally get to see.
But it's really cool to break that
down in people that you're close to,
people that you don't really know.
Just getting to share that common
knowledge and experience, and
be able to distill that.
And I think, therefore, understand
just people and humanity better,
taking home their stories and
remembering them is definitely one of
the big moments that I really cherish.
And still remember many of those talks.
>> I think, of course for
me, giving my talk and
that's when I came up with was a big
moment, and I did it in a trip.
So that's the other thing
I'm going to mention.
I was very focused on social innovation.
So I and the GSB has mandatory trip, well,
I don't know what to call it,
but I'm on the third trip abroad.
It can be their business trip or
a social focus trip, and I actually took.
So I went to India, that's in a mini
talk where I came out to my friends.
I went to South India on health care,
South Africa and education,
Kenya on social entrepreneurship.
And then I did a nonprofit trip non
official to Burundi, Rwanda, and Uganda.
And I think those trips are just amazing
the people you get to have conversations
with the expansion of
a global perspective.
And the friendships that you develop
from this trip is just amazing.
Yeah, I'll try emphasize
the talk that as well.
Definitely like hearing
other people's stories, but
then going through the process of
the reflection that was kind of like
a repeat of the what matters most
to you and why reflection process.
It was just doubling down and
doing it a bit more at least
that was the case for me.
Yeah, and I think I spent the first
like year or so, not kind of I
would say sharing all aspects of
my family background and life etc.
And so obviously that's not a great
way to start out an experience, but
I think the talk process kind
of helped me open up more.
I think it's helped me realize some of the
reasons that I was maybe holding back were
not really warranted.
And that it was like to my benefit, so
there's benefits to be more
transparent about that.
Related to that my second year,
myself and a couple of my classmates,
we helped start the first generation
low income diversity group at the GSB.
And I mean, I think the thing I took away
from that is how many conversations I had
with people about those things,
not just in my class but
in the class below me as well.
Of just like learning things
about others that otherwise,
I would not have learned if I had not
put myself out there in a certain way.
So I think that that's something
that I've taken away and
continue to think about a lot.
Obviously will certainly have
continued to have an impact in
the way that I interact with other people.
>> Yeah, thank you so much for
sharing that and I feel like you bring up,
something that I'm really
curious to learn more about is.
How did your GSB experience
impact the way you think about
the role of identity and
diversity in leadership?
I mean this panel is all
about diverse leaders and
I'm curious how your perspectives on that
evolved because of your GSB experience.
>> I could start, I mean, for
me it changed me completely.
And I think it took me a while to
find an organization to work for,
where my values, were aligned
in the way I learned to be and
I learn to be myself at the GSB so
it took me a while to get
to a place like Facebook.
I was interim country director for
Facebook, Mexico, and
when COVID hits, so
I was in charge of
managing the COVID crisis.
And what we saw and
the role that I had to take as a leader
was one of authenticity and vulnerability.
We did not have the answers,
and I was actually in charge of
helping a lot of Mexico CEOs.
And a lot of our clients and advertisers
work through that journey of showing up
authentically, showing
up with vulnerability.
I mean, and we still do have
people struggling with health,
mental health issues and whatnot.
And, yes, we are driving for
performance, but
caring of the individual as a whole has
been paramount to all of the efforts
that we've been doing and
that I learned at the GSB.
Like I couldn't have done that without
the tools that I learned at the GSB.
>> So I think prior to going to ten at
the GSB, I think my identity is like
being Latino, being like first
gen was not really top of mind.
Honestly it took a backseat
to a lot of other things for
most of my undergrad in my
professional career before MBA.
But arriving at Stanford, and I think, and
you'd see this in any kind of top business
school, just seeing that diversity
isn't really where it ought to be.
I think that kind of helped me, figure out
and I realized how important that was to
me and how much time I personally wanted
to dedicate to those issues like that.
So I don't know specifically how it's
influenced my own personal leadership
style, but it certainly has influenced
what I choose to invest my time in.
And what it is that I feel
like strong conviction around,
making sure that I raise my voice in.
So I mean, in addition to the first gen
income stuff, I was co-president for
the Hispanic Business student
Association while at Stanford.
But I also kind of the idea of
helping underserved communities was
always kind of a common theme in
my own personal career search.
And I'm pretty fortunate that I've
been able to land somewhere where I
feel that my job is
consistent with those values.
Even though I am working
at a VC backed startup.
I think it's pretty rare
that someone can say that.
So I think that it's, the perspective
I got from Stanford through that
kind of fueled my career search but also
kind of the way I look at the world and
how I want to operate within it.
>> 100% on that 100, like I couldn't have,
said that even better try to think
of an eloquent way to state that.
But I think my experience of
the GSB was one that magnified my
ability to realize,
my gosh, I'm a black woman.
And there's so much here that we
have to continue to press for or
toward if want to see more of
me at this school, in society.
And I'm using more of me, but I mean,
just like professional women,
professional black people at the table,
and
I have a strong positioning in doing that.
And so, that's what really I think
it kind of changed my calculus of
my career was thinking
about the opportunity as
a capital allocator to be able
to pour money into underserved
communities as a way of being able
to back underserved individuals.
And that being a catalyst into the trickle
down effect of who is employed and
who is making money.
And so it just really changed my
mindset in terms of my positioning and
the work that I want to do.
And how I want to serve communities and so
now my work I'm specifically focused on,
how can I invest in thinking about
diversity as a value enhancer?
So not a concessionary return type
of thing, but to say diversity,
the thing that's here to stay.
And I think that there's
a real value in that.
And so
how do I back diverse owned companies?
How do I put diverse people
into leadership positions and
governance positions.
And then think about the underlying
societies that they're serving.
So yeah, it's a huge push and
change of direction for me.
>> Awesome, thank you all for
sharing those reflections and
I feel like you all bring up
something that I want to acknowledge.
We're not a perfect institution,
we have work to do when it
comes to diversity and
to representation and to inclusion.
We're not perfect, and
that's something that I and
I think many of my colleagues
would transparently say.
One thing that I have admired during my
time at Stanford so far is that there's,
I think institutionally a will to change
and a responsiveness to students.
For example,
last summer as a response to the uprisings
against murders of black
folks by police forces,
Stanford GSB launched the action plan for
racial equity and
it's something that we're trying
to hold ourselves accountable to.
In the admissions office we are building
out partnerships with organizations
that support folks from underrepresented
or historically excluded backgrounds.
Such as Forte and
Management Leadership for Tomorrow.
So we're not a perfect
institution by any means.
But we are working to Be better.
And that's something that I do admire
about our community and our institution.
And I want to thank our panelists for
their transparency around that
because they know some of the best
purpose of these panels is to tell
the truth and and study at the GSB.
So I appreciate that from you all as well.
So I'm turning to our Q&A box, and
there are a couple questions I'm going to
see if I can kind of group them.
Well, there are a couple of questions
about sort of transitions and
the ways that the GSB might have
changed you, or changed your path.
So for example, Charles asks,
how has your what matters
most changed during and
after Stanford, if at all?
I think it's such an interesting question.
So I can say that again, how has your
what matters most changed during and
after Stanford, if at all?
>> It's a constant for me,
I think I just mostly write about
like my family and the legacy.
I feel like I'm creating and
that be opportunity or to take part of.
But yeah, what it boils down to is my
family and how much they mean to me and
how much it matters.
And so that's a constant,
it's my number one most
important thing value or
whatever, so that won't change.
>> Yeah, my what matters most to me and
why when I wrote my essay was basically
being a role model to younger
generation and underserved communities.
When I wrote that I had in mind basically
my nephews like other kids growing up in
my in my neighborhood,
I don't need to change too much.
I think the way that I would kind of
reframe it is like being a change agent to
support those individuals.
Now, I think that's more top of mind
now than it was before the GSB.
>> And I think that I mean,
you're listening to Alejandro and
Jessica, if you really write it right,
it doesn't change, right?
And more than changing permits being
a North Star when I left the GSB,
I joined consulting in the Bay Area.
And when I read it,
I was miserable in their role.
And it took me like one
night of reading it and
knowing that I needed to transition that
all of the things that I had built and
what I wanted to do and what was my
mission was not getting fulfilled there.
And so that's the reason why I decided
to go back to Mexico and then look for
opportunities where I could have
the impact that I wanted to have which was
Part of my whole what matters most to you.
And why so I think it's more for
North Star and in my change in phones and
whatever but if it's written correctly,
it should not change.
>> I love that, and I feel like I hear
that so often from our students and
from our alums about going
through the application process.
That often the very first step is
reflecting, going through that
process of introspection to really,
really figure out where you are,
where you want to go with your career,
what matters most to you and why.
And I feel like you capture that really,
really perfectly,
sort of on the,
I think if what matters most to you and
why is on the personal side on
the more professional side.
We do have a couple questions too
about career pivots, Nate says
I noticed Adriana and Ollie hundred
transitioned into the tech industry.
Could you share a specific experience
like a class club internship, etc,
at Stanford that had the largest impact
to prepare you for your current roles?
So I think that's a question that
all of you could could respond
to what's a class club internship that
Have the largest impact on you, and
prepare you for your current role.
Especially if you were pivoting,
which I believe actually all
three of you were pivoting into
into different industries.
So yeah, let's start there.
>> I can start, so, for me,
when I was coming into the GSB,
I had kind of said yeah, that I wanted to
work in autonomous vehicle technology.
That was largely informed by coming
from the insurance industry,
with wanting some way of
transitioning into tech.
That eventually kind of evolved and
turned into, labor marketplaces for
underserved communities,
specifically low wage workers.
I think the things the specific
classes that helped me get there,
it wasn't like a linear path,
but to help me get there was.
One was startup crush which
I'm sure many viewers
are familiar with the kind of the content
that's on the Stanford website.
And the other was data and
decisions, which is pretty random,
I don't think many people would attribute
any kind of like grouping from that class.
But I did get to work on a project with
a startup that was a marketplace and
that was the very first time I'd ever kind
of had first hand exposure with that type
of business model.
And that kind of got me really excited and
I ended up wanting to
go in that direction.
>> I can tell a little bit about
mine I ended up in tech by accident,
my career has not been as
planned as other people's.
But I think,
I'll talk about international and
I've worked in the US, I worked in
Mexico and I'm back in the US now.
And I think that gives you also
the very different perspective.
So when I moved back to Mexico,
what I wanted to do is maximize impact and
working to generate economic
empowerment in the country.
And so tech was an easy choice in that
regard because when I was offered a job at
PayPal it was to manage SMBs in
empowering digital payments for us.
And basically you can see the chain of
impacts why they didn't join because
it was the UK I joined because it was
the most scalable way to have impact.
And I joined in a commercial
function where particularly for
those who want to do tech abroad,
mostly outside of London,
Switzerland, Tel Aviv and
maybe a layover in Singapore,
most of the tech roles
tend to be commercial.
This would you develop a really
strong commercial acumen.
And so that's going back to the US,
I'm more focused on learning about product
which I haven't learned in my career.
But expanding that product components to
my skill set that is mostly commercial
on me the partnerships things.
I think classes specifically it's hard,
I mean of course,
you're going to have to use data and
whatnot.
But for me,
there's two critical classes one is and
I don't know if they still exist,
out almost ten years now.
It's got critical analytical thinking,
the biggest gap will see
in talent particularly in
emerging markets is critical and
analytical thinking when it comes to tech.
Data is now pervasive and it's how you
use that data, how you question, and
how do you do hypotheses or hypothesis
testing that's really important.
And the other one is your Peterson's
managing growing enterprises,
I use it every day is as a people leader
and as a people manager that can country
cases that you review and
the skill sets that you develop on people.
Literally, there's not a day where I
don't put some of that in practice.
>> Yeah, now there's a second
on a couple of different things,
I would I'd say two things in
terms of like career switching.
One thing that was really catalytic for
me and maybe it is inherent
in my approaches like is really
the people when I came to the GSB,
I explore a lot of different
careers by just talking to people.
Just like messaging,
I would have this goal and
it's a very mean, very planner type thing.
But reach out to three people every week,
related to whatever I was pursuing as well
as the GSB export a lot of different
ideas about things that I would enjoy.
And so we'd like to focus on
cornering that like industry or
sub industry to learn about it.
So that was one way and
actually what became a catalyst for
my career was one of my professors
just taking an interest in me.
But I took an interest first and
this professor like I was very forthcoming
about building relationships
not only with the by peers.
But also the faculty and professors and so
other professors are very catalytic and
helping me to think through and
get some exposure and venture.
Which led me to working in Andreessen
Horowitz after business school or
actually while in business school and
after business school.
And I would say on the kind of
like classes that were formative,
I would definitely double click
on managing growing enterprises.
I took it with grammar Weaver and it was
definitely something I like go back and
think about and, and
actually reference some of the materials.
Their negotiation class
was very like helpful.
It's Monday class, but just really
helpful in thinking about doing
better at negotiating and
actually negotiating.
I never negotiated for my career
prior to the GSB, and I think it's
especially a downfall of diverse people,
especially people of color and women.
There was another class acting with power,
specifically playing up or
playing down certain elements to just
do a better job at like showing up.
We can't all show up the same way every
day to to achieve our goals and just so
how do we think about our approach and
use them Kind of acting
techniques in which to do it.
And I could probably rattle on, but
those are just a couple that
really stood out for me.
>> So thank you all so
much for those insights.
>> Let me see, Rashmi asked a question
that I'm curious about as well.
Rashmi asks,
what surprised you the most about
the GSB once you started the program.
And I'm also curious, were there any,
not just surprises, but any.
Preconceptions you had about the GSB or
myths that were debunked or confirmed.
Once you arrived on campus
>> I
say the MBA itself and actually
can speak to other experiences but
someone told me in my
internship before the GSB.
That they, I remember specifically having
a meeting with them and they're like,
your experience is going to go like this,
like this, like this.
And I was like, okay,
I really don't know what that means,
it's you're going to classes, I've been
to undergrad I've studied before so
I'm not really sure what the like
this like this, like this is but
it was actually
>> A perfect description of like,
I think what I experience
just being in a place,
taking yourself away from
generally close like family and
friends and being a different environment.
I think where your goal is to
grow is buried Difficult and
just hard sometimes,
which like led to like multiple,
like crying sessions and
it was never necessarily anything dire.
But I think that personal growth
really does take some time and
take some, energy like ups and
downs to kind of get there.
And I think that that was probably
one of the most like catalyst things,
whenever any experience of substantive
challenge, I've always come out of it and
been a much better person.
And so, I was definitely surprised by that
cause I thought I would like grow and
be academically smarter and
come out with more friends.
But didn't think about actually
the journey being something that
would Be sometimes arduous.
>> Yeah.
For me, I think there's so
many things that surprise you and
I completely agree with Jessica but
Then again being very sensitive to
the context, the amount of travelling.
When you're not from North America,
you think you're global,
you think,
we're not like North America centric.
I have a global perspective and I really
did not have a global perspective,
the world really opened up for
me in that way and
the cultures that I that I was
able to know and experience.
And just through classmates and traveling
I think it was an amazing experience.
On the negative side and
speaking on the nature of the GSB and
how we work on changing things.
I have barely come out in Mexico and
I was like, I'm coming to the Bay Area.
This is like brain both town and
lo and behold when I joined
there was only one lesbian in the two
classes openly So I was in shock.
I just couldn't believe that and
we we did a lot of work on this.
And I think that that's where you see
the GPSP commitment on how to do that and
how to make sure we and
it was also a different time.
Because if you look back at
the classes now, there's 10, but
it's how you get people to be comfortable
with who they are, as as they progress.
I think also being It's not the same, like
being a woman, you're already a minority
being a lesbian that intersectionality
matters, and that's what we saw.
And that's what we analyze the how we work
towards being more present in our MBA like
having more female presence because
he was mostly a male presence.
And I know there was a lot of
investment in that area, but
that was something that I was very shocked
when when I got there coming from Mexico,
particularly
>> For
me, I think on the travel piece like
obviously I had heard from like brands and
like what the travel culture
was like most MBA programs.
It was definitely ended up being
a lot more than I anticipated.
And before the GSB I'd been to like two
countries outside of The US by the end
of it I've been to 13 so
like obviously it's like no.
That's something that I chose to like
take a lot they could take advantage of.
So that's definitely a positive the the
thing that I think I didn't see coming and
that I need to adjust to it's kind of
what Jessica was describing around like
the the waves of just
things hitting you are.
And there's just a lot of momentum as soon
as you arrive on campus that if you're not
taking the time to stop and
be intentional.
But which way kind of you're pointing,
you can easily get swept up in whatever
is kind of happening on campus, right?
Whether that'd be social events,
or the outings traveling or
what's the extracurricular activities
that seem the most fun right.?
There were definitely plenty of
times where I had to stop and
reflect kind of similar to what.
The reflection I had done before GSB just
to make sure that I was kind of doing
the things that were in line with
what I wanted to achieve long term.
And I thought it was good
at time management but
I realized I needed to get better
while I was at school, old school.
[LAUGH]
>> Thank you all for those responses.
I'm curious.
You all mentioned different sort of
challenges that you encountered that.
Wondering how did you choose
what were the resources or
support systems that you drew
upon to weather those challenges.
I mean,
I think there's a myriad of resources.
So for me, I joined the diversity board.
And what's great to see there and
listening both to Alex and
Jessica is how that evolves, right?
Because people were saying were you
addressing the racial injustice issue?
Well, it wasn't in a stage where we were
aware we were addressing the issues that
were current at that time and they were
pressing issues and so you can see how
Having that active leadership and
having a body that can support that is so
meaningful and so important for
transformation not only of us, but
of the school culture and
the school principals and whatnot.
I think classmates, it takes a while.
I've been out for ten years almost,
but it takes a while for
people to start opening up
about how they're struggling.
But once they do it, it's like collective.
And so you have a lot of support groups
and you also have, I don't know,
the course of poets when you're
not from a science background.
And I remember we had the Dead Poets
Society in winter quarter which also
changed, because all of the quantum
classes were in one quarter and
it was going to third quarter.
But we all got together,
we had extra classes by TAs,
even the professors would engage to make
sure that we felt supported as we've
navigated those academic challenges.
I think for
everything [INAUDIBLE] it's just amazing.
There's a resource or you can get
funding or there's friends, anything.
It's multidimensional how you get support
as you're facing these challenges.
>> So many resources is all I can say,
same things as Adriana.
I mean, just broadly,
I'll just talk about the resources.
Not necessarily related
to their challenges, but
I use a communications
coach when I was there.
I went to the career resource center.
I don't know how many times just
chatting with the people there about
opportunities and anywhere I saw myself
as I was exploring opportunities.
There's our academic advisor for
our section who I loved so
couple of times.
And then there's just resources that are
just outside of the GSB beyond the people
that are there, which I think Adriana
already mentioned, like your peers.
Gosh, there's tutoring.
[LAUGH] I definitely needed a tutor for
some of the classes.
And so I was like peer tutors so
that was super helpful.
And then just outside the GSB,
a number of people in my
class are very open about seeing why
am I losing the my train of thought.
But basically, seeing some of the
facilitators related to psychological or
any type of mental healthcare things.
It's a great resource long that and
there's no stigma attached to it.
I feel it almost has to do by no one went
to that center, I forget the name of it.
And there's just like resources a bound
on I agree on whatever you need.
There's that and then the second year, I
found like a meditation center on campus.
So I would go to a meditation center and
just like take the time to breathe.
So anyway, there's more resources than
you will have the opportunity to use.
>> Yeah, I would agree with
definitely the career supports.
I think that was like pretty important for
me since I was doing
like startup recruiting.
There was no kind of structured
way of recruiting for that and
kind of really relates to having
like the alumni network was huge.
I got two internships
during while I was at GSB.
One over the summer and
then one during second year,
both were through alumni network
connects from cold outreach.
And basically,
getting the ball moving that way.
So those are huge and I would also
agree with Jessica on the Stanford wide
resources when it comes to mental health.
I personally took advantage
of like a therapy and
mental health services
that were offered there.
And that made a big difference for
me while I was going through
the business school program.
And again, I know many of my peers
to do banjo research as well and
they were also folks that were
very forthcoming with that.
And, yeah, there definitely is no stigma.
There's a lot of acceptance around like
you gotta do what you gotta do to take
care of yourself.
And think people are openly and kind of
willing there to be supportive of you,
whatever that means.
>> Appreciate all of those insights.
There's a great question
from Mike Sauce or Mike.
[LAUGH] Who asked,
what sets the GSB apart from other schools
with regards to diversity and inclusion?
I'll give you a second to think
about that and repeat the question.
What sets the GSB apart
from other schools or
what's distinctive about the GSP with
respect to diversity and inclusion?
>> And I get we're all struggling a bit,
because it's hard to say,
because we didn't go to those schools.
And we're super cognizant of
the fact that we didn't, so
it would only be by what
other people have told me.
I would say what I think is
distinctive is what I start off by
saying which is a real intent to
do things differently and change.
And to listen and be open and honest, and
have real conversations with one another.
That could happen on other places I don't
know but I think it's like what under life
the culture of Stanford that creates these
true conversations where we can be real
with one another about this
made me feel this way.
And also just the tools,
we're actually given the tools through
interpersonal dynamics [INAUDIBLE]
to be able to have real conversations
to lean into what's uncomfortable.
And, yeah, to just dig into what would
generally be taboo conversation.
So I would say that of the experience.
But, yeah, I can't holistically speak
to what other universities are doing or
what it's like.
Just the culture of the GSB is
what resonates most for me.
>> Yeah, for me, I didn't go to other
schools, but I could tell you that
the spirit and that fight for
making the world a better place continues.
So I'm class of 2012.
And with all the social unrest in the US
last year, my class got together and
we actually have not only a WhatsApp
working group where we share resources.
And I'm sad Laurie was not here,
because she's part of that group.
But basically, we have a lot of
sets of people which is amazing.
Because then,
we get together every quarter since
it's been like a year and a half now.
And we discuss what are the practices that
we are establishing in our own companies.
How we can share those to make
sure that we create a better and
more inclusive place in
where we're working.
And that just talks about the spirit of
the GSB and the people who are at the GSB
and people who really just have a mindset
of how do we create a better and
more inclusive place for everyone?
>> I'll just reiterate what Jessica said,
I have no idea what
other programs are like.
I assume they're similar, but
I think what I observed that at the GSB
from being there from beginning of
the first year where I was kind
of plugged into diversity initiatives,
being on HPSA board.
I was very kind of plugged in and
aware of what the broader administration
was doing and it's not perfect.
But what I have seen is
like a lot of progress and
a lot of willingness to understand
what it is that students need,
what an alumni need in
order to improve that.
So I think most recently,
the GSB was working through like a racial
equity task force that I participated in.
That basically, brought together alumni
from across many different generations to
talk about a lot of these issues that were
top of mind for students and alums and
the rest of our community.
And basically,
with the intention of figuring out
what actions the GSB needed to take.
To my knowledge, I haven't heard
of other programs doing that or
having similar initiatives.
So I think to me, that kind of speaks
volumes of what the GSB is willing to do,
at least in terms of listening to
start considering kind of plans for
improving diversity.
>> Thank you all for those insights.
I feel like you've each
touched on the sort of mission
orientation of Stanford GSB and
of the community, and
we have a few questions about social
innovation opportunities, and
resources at the GSB or
about are about opportunities.
And support for pursuing careers
that are maybe a little bit for
quote, unquote, off the off
the beaten path that might be in
social innovation or nonprofit or
education or that explore or
fulfill some of those goals around
serving under represented or
under resourced communities.
Could you all speak a little bit
to opportunities resources in
social innovation or
social impact at the GSB?
>> I didn't do a good job at taking
advantage of all the resources, but
I think my approach to social impact was
just it should just be a part of the DNA.
So I ended up taking away a certificate,
because I took so many classes on social
impact, because they're just that
interesting to me that was never the goal.
There are many different resources
that are focused on impact investing.
There's a social innovation club.
You'll find a lot of those different
interests to build a lot of people that
share those interests on campus just
through kind of formal aggregating bodies.
And I'd say if you want to just do
something different, Stanford is a great
place to be even if you're feeling
like this is like a one of one thing.
I was Initially came in thinking that
I wanted to do like a food startup.
And in terms of food and beverage,
there weren't a lot of us
are represented in that group.
But I think therein lies the opportunity
like the alumni group is so
large, the community is really
large to be able to fulfill that.
So what I advise is just doing
what I said earlier, just
making sure that you get out there and
start talking to people and ask people.
Do you know someone in this industry?
Moreover, something I advise to all of the
people that I talked to that are headed to
business school or
going soon is what do you want your
brand to be when you arrive on campus?
What's your one liner?
What do you want to be known for?
Because that's gobba stick with you.
And if people know you as the woman
who's interested in social innovation
in East Africa, those opportunities
will magnetize to you, but
you need to be able to communicate what
that is two people if that makes sense.
And so if you say that a bunch of times
and you say that to your class of 400,
you're going to get a lot of opportunity.
Because within the community people,
their intent is to help and they're
going to want to see you be successful.
So I would think at that wherever you go,
wherever you end up just
like what's your tagline and
how do you start to kind of
magnetize those opportunities.
>> I also had the certificate.
One resource is the DISCO, I took
a bunch of classes at the DISCO design.
The famous way, I remember the name.
The famous one, but
then I also had the same for location.
I had a bunch of classes around
different social issues.
But it has been interesting for me to
ten years out with all of my friends who
were interested and all of us who
were taking the social innovation and
social impact classes is how
our careers have shifted.
And so some of us think of our
impact in a different way.
So the way, I think about it at Facebook
is we're enabling connectivity.
We're enabling opportunity.
I serve the SPG segment
again in my new role.
And so what we can do is different and
then you see, so my friends who I know
we're in impact investing before,
then went full on corporate and
are now in a corporate environment but
in East Africa, for example.
So it's taking different ways and
not necessarily doing the for
profit mission driven companies and
that's I think how amazing it is on.
My perspective potentially was just
broadened by the researchers than
the friendships that I formed in
the purview that I was able to shape at
the GSB.
>> I actually didn't kind of pursue any
of the social innovation coursework.
I think the the classes I ended
up choosing were more focused on,
I guess like traditional
startup ecosystem work.
But the one thing I will say that is
probably relevant to this is while you're
a students reaching out to folks
outside of the GSB network just like
folks that are working in an area
that you're interested in.
Whether it be like specific innovations
based, social impact type role even if
they're not GSB affiliated while you're at
Stanford kind of hearing from students,
specifically GSB that business school
students is actually really good.
You're very likely to get a response.
So like use the time that while
you're in school to reach out
network with those individuals that are in
your kind of area of career interests,
because you'll you'll actually learn to
end up getting being able to connect with
a lot more folks then than if you kind of
wait until after you're done with school.
That's just my personal experience from
a networking for startups and other areas.
>> So I know we're coming up on time.
For our attendees,
you'll see that we have a poll.
We want to know how we're doing.
Ultimately, our events
are all about serving you.
So we want to know if we're doing a good
job and we take your feedback very,
very seriously.
With our last minute,
there is one last question and
I'll ask our panelists to be brief
in their responses if they could,
but I love this question.
There's a question asking, when you think
back about your experience at Stanford,
what are you most grateful for?
So this will be a lightning round.
What are you most grateful for
when you think back about
your experience at Stanford?
>> The people.
[LAUGH]
>> That was one, Amber.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That was a layer, thank you.
>> Well, thank you all so much for
spending a bit of your day with us and
thank you to our incredible panelists for
sharing your stories and
sharing your experiences with us and
with all of our attendees tonight.
I hope you all have
a great rest of your day.
And if you have any other questions,
please feel free to get in touch with us.
We are here to serve you and
we're 100% in your corner.
So thank you again to our attendees and
thank you so
much again to our amazing panelists.
Have a good night.
[MUSIC]